la première commotion que nous avons mesurée avec cet instrument.
J'insiste sur le fait qu'il est équipé d'un gyroscope
qui permet de mesurer la rotation de la tête.
La plupart des experts pensent qu'il s'agit du facteur critique
pour commencer à comprendre ce qu'il se passe pendant une commotion.
Voici la vidéo.
Présentateur : Cougars vient en renfort tardivement, mais Luck a le temps.
Winslow s'est effondré.
J'espère qu'il va bien.
(Encouragements du public)
En haut de votre écran,
vous allez le voir apparaître,
se démarquer, dans la zone sûre.
Le voici à vitesse réelle. Écoutez ça !
Le coup est donné par...
David Camarillo : Trois fois, c'est un peu trop.
Mais vous avez compris.
Rien qu'en visionnant ce film,
on comprend qu'il a reçu un coup incroyable et qu'il est blessé.
Quand on extrait les données
du protège-dents qu'il porte,
on détecte davantage de détails, une information plus riche.
Une des choses que nous avons remarquées,
c'est qu'il a été percuté sur la partie inférieure gauche de son casque,
qui a causé un mouvement contre-intuitif.
Sa tête n'a pas bougé vers la droite.
Elle a d'abord fait une rotation vers la gauche.
Ensuite, quand le cou a commencé à se comprimer,
la force du coup l'a balayée vers la droite.
Le mouvement gauche-droite ressemble donc à celui d'un essuie-glace.
Nous pensons que c'est ça qui a causé la lésion au cerveau.
Les limites de notre instrument font qu'il ne mesure
que les mouvements du crâne,
or, nous voulons savoir ce qui se passe dans le cerveau.
Nous avons donc collaboré avec l'équipe de Svein Kleiven en Suède,
qui a développé un modèle en éléments finis du cerveau.
Voici la simulation de la blessure,
réalisée au départ des données transmises par notre protège-dents.
Vous remarquerez que le cerveau,
ceci en est une coupe transversale,
le cerveau se tord et se contorsionne, comme je vous l'ai expliqué.
C'est très différent de la vidéo du CCPM.
Les couleurs indiquent l'intensité de l'étirement des tissus.
En rouge : 50%.
Ça signifie que les tissus du cerveau dans cette zone précise
ont été étirés 50% en plus que leur forme d'origine,
Je voudrais attirer votre attention sur ce point rouge.
Ce point rouge est très proche du centre du cerveau,
et si on compare cela avec la surface extérieure,
on y constate peu de coloration d'une telle intensité,
contrairement à ce qui apparaît sur la vidéo du CCPM.
Pour vous présenter les détails
de ce que nous pensons survenir au moment d'une commotion,
et je dois préciser,
que nous avons constaté, avec d'autres,
qu'une commotion risque plus d'arriver
quand sur le choc, la tête fait une rotation comme ceci.
Ça arrive plus souvent au football américain,
mais ce sens semble plus dangereux.
Que se passe-t-il ici ?
D'abord, la particularité qui distingue le cerveau humain
de celui des autres animaux,
est le fait qu'il est composé de deux grands lobes.
Nous avons l'hémisphère gauche et le droit.
L'élément crucial de cette image,
c'est qu'il y a au centre des deux hémisphères
une grande scissure qui plonge au cœur du cerveau.
Dans cette scissure, et on ne la voit pas sur l'image,
vous devez me croire,
il y a une membrane fibreuse, appelée faux du cerveau.
Cette membrane va de l'os pariétal jusqu'à la nuque.
Elle est assez rigide.
Elle permet ceci : quand on est percuté
et que la tête fait une rotation de gauche à droite,
les forces sont transmises rapidement au cœur du cerveau.
Qu'y a-t-il au fond de cette scissure ?
Il y a la centrale nerveuse de votre cerveau.
En fait, le faisceau rouge au fond de la scissure
est le plus grand faisceau fibreux
qui interconnecte les deux hémisphères cérébraux.
Ça s'appelle le corps calleux.
Nous pensons que c'est là qu'agit
un des mécanismes les plus habituels des commotions :
quand les forces se déplacent vers l'intérieur,
elles déforment le corps calleux.
Ça provoque une dissociation entre les deux hémisphères.
Ça pourrait expliquer certains symptômes des commotions.
Cette découverte est cohérente avec ce que nous avons constaté
dans l'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique.
Voici une image d'un ancien joueur professionnel de football américain.
Observez le corps calleux.
Comparez la taille d'un corps calleux d'un cerveau sain,
et celle de cette personne souffrant d'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique.
Le corps calleux est très atrophié.
On constate la même chose pour tous les espaces des ventricules.
Ces ventricules sont beaucoup plus grands.
Tous ces tissus proches du centre du cerveau
sont morts avec le temps.
Nos découvertes sont donc cohérentes.
La bonne nouvelle,
et j'espère que vous conserverez de l'espoir après ma présentation,
la bonne nouvelle dans nos observations,
et qui concerne les mécanismes des lésions,
est que certes, la transmission des forces est très rapide,
elle prend néanmoins un certain temps.
Nous pensons que si nous arrivons à ralentir le mouvement de la tête
suffisamment pour que le cerveau ne traîne pas derrière le crâne,
mais bouge de manière synchrone avec le crâne,
nous pourrions prévenir les mécanismes à l'origine des commotions.
Comment pouvons-nous ralentir la tête ?
(Rires)
Un casque géant.
Avec l'espace, on a plus de temps.
C'est une plaisanterie mais certains connaissent peut-être ceci.
C'est un vrai sport. Ça s'appelle le foot bulle.
J'ai déjà vu des jeunes adultes
en jouer près de chez moi.
A ma connaissance, aucune commotion à signaler.
(Rires)
Plaisanterie à part, le principe tient la route.
Mais dans ce cas, ça va trop loin.
Ce n'est pas pratique pour rouler à vélo ou jouer au football.
Nous collaborons avec une entreprise suédoise appelée Hövding.
Certains parmi vous connaissent leurs produits.
Ils utilisent le même principe de gain d'espace supplémentaire avec de l'air,
pour éviter les commotions.
Les enfants, n'essayez pas ça à la maison.
Ce cascadeur n'a pas de casque.
A la place, il a un col autour du cou.
Ce col est muni de capteurs,
identiques à ceux dans mon protège-dents.
Le col détecte le début de la chute,
un airbag se déclenche et gonfle,
de la même manière qu'un airbag agit dans votre voiture.
Nous avons réalisé des expériences dans mon labo avec ce col.
Nous avons découvert qu'il réduit grandement les risques de commotions
dans certains scénarii, par rapport à un casque normal.
C'est très encourageant.
Mais pour que nous puissions réaliser les avantages de cette technologie
qui peut empêcher les commotions,
elle doit être conforme aux réglementations.
C'est un fait à prendre en compte.
Cet instrument est en vente en Europe,
mais pas aux États-Unis.
Et ne le sera sans doute pas avant longtemps.
Je vais vous en expliquer la raison.
Il y a des bonnes et des moins bonnes raisons.
Les casques à vélo sont sous réglementation fédérale.
La Commission pour la Sécurité des Produits de Consommation
a pour mission d'homologuer un casque,
et voici leur test.
Rappelez-vous ce que je vous ai dit à propos des fractures du crâne.
C'est ce que test vérifie.
C'est important de le faire.
Ça peut vous sauver la vie, mais ce n'est pas suffisant.
Par exemple, ce test n'évalue pas
et ne nous dit pas si l'airbag va se déclencher
au bon moment et au bon endroit,
et pas quand ce n'est pas nécessaire.
Ça ne ne nous dit pas
si ce casque va éviter une commotion.
Les casques de football américain, qui ne sont pas sous ces réglementations,
subissent des tests similaires.
Ils ne sont pas sous réglementation fédérale.
Il y a un instance industrielle, ça fonctionne ainsi.
Mais l'instance industrielle, croyez-moi, est assez résistante
à améliorer leurs standards.
Par conséquent, mon labo ne se limite pas aux mécanismes de commotion.
Il s'attache aussi à comprendre comment améliorer les standards.
Nous espérons que le gouvernement utilisera ces informations
pour encourager l'innovation,
en permettant aux consommateurs de prendre connaissance
le degré de protection offert par tel ou tel casque.
Je reviens à ma question de départ :
serais-je à l'aise à l'idée que mon enfant
fasse du football américain, ou roule à vélo ?
Je suis sans doute influencé par ma propre expérience traumatique,
mais je suis beaucoup plus anxieux quand ma fille, Rose, roule à vélo.
Elle a un an et demi.
Elle est prête à dévaler les rues de San Francisco.
Voici le bas d'une de ces rues.
Mon objectif personnel, et je crois qu'il est réalisable,
est de développer ces technologies.
Nous travaillons dans mon labo à un projet précis
qui optimise l'espace dans un casque.
Je suis convaincu que nous pourrons,
avant que ma fille ne roule sur un vélo à deux roues,
avoir un équipement à disposition
qui puisse vraiment réduire le risque de commotion
et qui soit conforme aux réglementations.
Ce que je souhaite donc faire,
pour certains d'entre vous, la question est imminente,
moi, j'ai encore quelques années,
c'est pouvoir affirmer aux parents et grands-parents qui me le demanderont,
que leur enfant peut s'engager dans ces activités en toute sécurité.
J'ai beaucoup de chance, mon équipe à Stanford est incroyable.
Ils s'investissent à fond dans ce projet.
J'espère donc pouvoir revenir d'ici quelques années,
avec le mot de la fin.
Mais pour le moment,
je vous dirai de ne pas craindre le mot commotion.
Il y a de l'espoir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)